so the byline of this vice article she
gets 1.7 million seven less investors
from gets five percent of her creator
earnings for 30 years
so you're saying hey she's gonna make at
least a million a year in order for you
just to break even yeah but uh investing
that money for 30 years you really need
to do what five or ten times that amount
absolutely yeah and that's what it's
venture capital right in the end of the
day like marina you know is not who's
the one you're referencing was in the
article she's not at zero like she's
making pretty meaningful money already
she has a meaningful following but she's
a season opportunity where she can take
investment dollars from us and
dramatically improve her business and
like with the scope of what she's able
to do i mean i think that's you know for
a creator this deal makes sense it makes
sense for her if she's like if i can
raise my my earnings by five percent
this deal pays for itself
right like in a sense and then for us
we're basically betting like venture
capitalists that actually she's gonna
crush it right that providing the right
seed capital the right team can
dramatically change the outcome in terms
of what she's capable of producing in
her career and we want to benefit along
with with her in that so she's not mr
beast with whatever you know crazy tens
of million subscribers she's got 4.6
million subscribers on youtube which is
really hard to do but so she's
definitely
cleared like being a notable celebrity
she might make below millions of dollars
a year or something like that what is
she in the business of currently what is
her youtube channel about what attracted
you to her business as the first one
she has a few um and i think that's
partially what we look for is like some
level of versatility right but like part
of her brand is built around you know
russians learning american business
culture um and things like that because
she's an immigrant and has a great story
around that she does you know some other
stuff around culture she has a bunch of
interesting audiences that she's built
together you know with a few different
channels and our view is like again like
this is something we want to be aligned
with long term we think she's going to
do a lot more really interesting work in
her career it's not necessarily about
owning one specific niche or one
audience it's about if you're investing
in somewhere over a 30-year time horizon
you're really investing in their growth
right as people as leaders as business
people you know as creators in a lot of
ways shapes or forms now if david dobrik
or mr beast or someone came and said hey
i would love financing would we do it
absolutely right it looks more like a
growth deal right it's not a venture
deal um but there's no reason in the end
of the day the basic thesis which is you
know businesses are getting smaller and
smaller right you know it used to be
thousands of people now 10 now can be
individual creators finance should be
able to scale down and flex right to
support these individual creators why
not right um
and if she were to create five companies
in that time you would get five percent
of those companies as well so that's
fantastic five percent of her of her
equity in the company is it right
right so if somebody gave her 20 of a
perfume brand you would be getting one
point of that hundred point pi or five
percent of right twenty percent yeah
exactly uh which makes total sense so
tell me about what that negotiation was
like did she understand this is the
first time
i think anybody's done this to the best
of my knowledge right i mean i've never
heard of anybody investing in a crater
people have tried forms of this i mean i
think that you know one of the things i
really appreciate about marina and
working let's do with her she totally
gets it from day one and then actually
was a really great i wouldn't say
sparring partner but person to work with
to actually work out the kinks on how to
do this right um because she's
sophisticated she has good lawyers
around her
you know this is the type of thing you
actually you know especially as an
investor if we came in and you know like
bowled in a china shop and made up some
deal with some creator didn't understand
anything right like it doesn't serve
anyone right it doesn't serve us from a
brand perspective we want to do more of
these doesn't serve the creator you know
but what was cool about working with her
and we did work very closely on several
iterations of how to actually paper this
and make it work and the details and how
do you think about self-employment taxes
and like really structuring it properly
was you know i think that we got to a
really great place where you know
everyone's like yep this deal works it's
papered as we intend it and we can roll
it out and do way more of them right um
in a scalable way so you know again it
was a negotiation in terms of like how
do we come up with fair prices how do i
have lps like i need to present them
with a deal that makes sense like if it
doesn't make sense for them it doesn't
make sense you know she has to want to
do the deal right so like we need to
find a good space in there um you know
and a good model that works for everyone
so she's incented to generate as much
revenue as possible she gets to keep 95
of everything she makes but she gets to
get this big chunk of change now to
deploy to build her brand how she sees
fit right so
is it a company of her or
how do you structure it i'm curious is
it an llc or something yeah it's an
obviously created investment llc which
she controls right we don't control it
you know it sits kind of alongside and
has contractual rights to basically a
piece of her earn out so you know most
creators even at this scale even you
know when you're getting going they do
have some sort of earn out or llc right
which they should right and like you
know and so we basically kind of sit
alongside that as a separate entity that
she controls we have certain information
rights that are pretty
meaningful but limited we try to make it
super simple right so that we can kind
of get some transparency on what's going
on but beyond that our whole thing is
like we don't want to make money if
you're not making money right if you are
making money below a certain level we
don't want to be paid our goal is not to
be paid on the marginal case right we
don't want to be taking money you need
but look if you end up building the next
mr beast's brand or
become the next jeff bezos right or the
next elon elon you know the ultimate
cult leader
you know the reality is is like was the
up if the upfront financing helped you
get to there that's a great outcome and
then the beauty of venture which you
know well jason is
that your super winners pay for all the
losers right which means the actual the
irony is that it's the cheapest money
available right which is partially why
people was like 30 years is so long like
it's all about alignment right as long
as i'm aligned with the winning cases
there's no back door where i can bet on
elon musk but not end up making that
five percent then i can make the cost of
capital so much lower for everyone else
right because i know that whereas you
know there's a lot of other products out
there you know like people talk about
isas income sharing agreements right the
problem with isas is they're pretty
expensive because they're so limited
right they kind of cap out so quickly
they do one thing right they they'll
send you to
lamb to school or
nursing school and instead of you paying
50k for nursing school or 40k whatever
it is
they'll pick that up and they basically
want you to return double for them
taking the risk which seems reasonable
over like a 10-year period but you have
to break a minimum right did you come up
with a minimum she has to make yeah in
order to take the five percent
absolutely the minimum on our our
version of deals i'm sure much higher
than any isa you'll ever find out there
thousands of dollars i would've said
yeah because we're not trying to
monetize you know if non-winning cases
right but i think you know again i'm not
against isas i think they're an
interesting product and an important one
we've invested in the ecosystem but i
think the the fundamental difference is
isas always have a cap in them they say
you're not going to pay us more than 2x
the value of the education or whatever
and i understand why but what that means
is that the actual cost for everyone's
much higher
right where it's almost like you know
whereas if you do our version of the
deal which is an uncapped upside and the
average cost would be much lower right
and then in fairness you kind of can
project what a nurse is going to make
you know a developer over a
non-entrepreneurial nurse or developer
let's say which is a whole different
category this is an entrepreneur
okay everybody let's take a moment to
talk about growth marketing and all the
tactics and hacks that are out there
with me today jake badgard he is the ceo
and founder of disruptive advertising
which you can visit at
disruptiveadvertising.com
twist
so some questions for you jake when is
too early to start marketing your cyber
monday uh or your black friday what's
the right time to engage people and how
do you engage them yeah you know that's
going to depend on the audience but that
the cheapest customer is the person
that's already bought from you before
and it's time today to start warming up
the audience that bought from you last
year
with custom audiences on social or email
it's time to get on top of those right
now and getting them warm and ready to
engage
as far as new audiences are concerned
there's a lot of opportunity to explore
new platforms outside of the traditional
google facebook
channels uh like uh instagram instagram
tick tock some of these other ones
linkedin
youtube let's get some new audiences in
place and test those out and find what's
working so that we're ready to scale
when game time comes all right that's
great advice so if you want to sign up
for a free digital marketing audit with
jake and his company disruptive
advertising just visit disruptive
advertising.com twist and if you go into
business with disruptive you will
receive a 250 gift card and a free
friday to sunday ski trip in utah uh
we'll see you on the slopes gonna be a
great season